[Musik]
Christine Bol kämpft mit allen
Mitteln sie muss eine Institution der
Schweiz retten
die spezielle Moment ich weiß jetzt ist
ein spezieller Moment das hilft so im
[Musik]
Fokus
die größte Publikumsmesse steht auf dem
Spiel dort wo sich sonst Jahr für Jahr
die Bundesrätinnen und Bundesräte mit
einem säuli ablichten lassen die Olma
gilt als Leuchtturm für die Ostschweiz
jeden Herbst planieren über 300 000
Menschen während 11 Tagen von Stand zu
Stand nun steht der gesamte Messebetrieb
wegen Corona in finanzieller Schieflage
es droht die
Pleite
[Musik]
F 30 Millionen aus der
Geschäftstätigkeit wo man braucht hättet
plus der Bau ist nat also aus Corona F
coronaazit F 40 Millionen Franken die
Olma ist nicht systemrevant das ist
nicht eine klassische Staatsaufgabe man
kann nicht immer danach bet jetzt ist
fertig jetzt geben wir noch einmal etwas
aber dann muss es selber stehen
[Musik]
es ist April ich bin das erste mal mit
Christine Bolt unterwegs ich begleite
Sie auf Ihrem Kampf um die Millionen bis
im Oktober will sie die Olma gerettet
haben national national div Mitglieder V
Parlament verwtungsrat haben einen
ambitionierten Rettungsplan mit drei
großen Etappen zelen die Genossenschaft
in eine AG wandeln eine Finanzspritze
der Politik und Millionen mit Sponsoren
und fanaktien
sammeln man B öffentlichen hoff dass man
irgendw groß Geldgeber findet ja die
hoff ja ich hoffe
vertrau
Lust auch zeichnet und dass die auch
witer und natürlich ja wenn sich ein
große Geldgeber finden L ist nicht
schlecht da dur gut
il
cool wir sind an der Frühlingsmesse
offer bereits hier will sie aus der Not
eine Tugend
machen frisch und unkomplizierter mess
oder
wus Mens Frau jung
und nicht graue alte weiße Männer in
schwarzwies und
[Gelächter]
grauwi
mod
publikumü sich hier Wirtschafts und
politprominente ich höre wie sich
Christine Bolt mit der einen oder dem
anderen gleich für ein Geschäftsmeeting
verabredet an der Seite der Olmer
Direktorin ein langjähriges
Geschäftsleitungsmitglied h
unterscheidet sich Christine Bol von
Vorgänger ja also es ist natürlich Frau
und es ist eine andere
Generation Direktor standandene ältere
her viicht oder und das sind auch andere
schwerpünkte im Lauf der zit wo im mal
wieder wichtig sie sind und jetzt mit
der chrtin SCH da wo sehr nach am Markt
ist natürlich Marketing
Hintergrund wo im
Denken sehr sehr Hüttig ist weiß
Zielgruppen und da füro Produkt extrem
wertvoll sich
im so schwierige Frage ganz ehrlich mit
der
Freundin ich fre m wirklich auf G stimm
ne entdeck
undü das sind so die Moment W weiß warum
das man
kämpf also
du ist es ist fest wie und F es GT im
ganz so der Charakter wo
du machen
oderank
ich kenne die Messe als eine große
Gewerbeausstellung vor 20 Jahren habe
ich selber einmal hier gearbeitet dem
Erlebnis wird heutzutage viel mehr
Beachtung geschenkt das ist auch nötig
um sich gegen die Konkurrenz im
Onlinehandel zu
behaupten während der Messetage hat
Christine Bolt immer ein gedräktes
Programm alle wollen sie sehen und sie
möchte alle begrüßen
[Musik]
guten Morgen Mitarbeiterinnen versuchen
die Olmer Volksaktie zu verkaufen für
1100 Franken pro Aktie gemäß
Rettungsplan sollen so insgesamt 20
Millionen Franken zusammenkommen aus
meiner Sicht eine schier unmögliche
Aufgabe
abertf
grün da da
ja
ja es ist ein Kampf und Millionen waso
sie da führt wie got s es geht
Moment wir sind in der schwierigste
Phase Krise wir sind in Transformation
wach Bau und derit schon mega streng 20
Millionen such ja g Moment und ich
fin ich GL schaff se breit abstü Region
und da wird langfristig wier Fundament
geh Christine Bolt arbeitete im
Marketing und war Leiterin des
lesermarktes bei einem Zeitungsverlag
sie weiß wie man sich gut vermarktet tut
dies auch in der Medienmitteilung der
Messe ist jetzt so wichtig zum Botschaft
transportieren das Geschäftsmodell
funktioniert wir gewün wir sind zück es
ist wieder da also was was Bedütig und
schon wichtig dass man da zeig und da
hab wir jetzt wirklich bewies es ist
nicht einfach geschwätzt es ist der
bewies oder so wie d Titel so Pressetext
probiert man immer knackig und gut zu
verkaufen probiert man da la übertrieben
oder einfach wirklich so zu verkaufen
dass Strategie spürbar ist ich selber
bin nicht ein Fan von übertriebige aber
ich glaub es ist wichtig dass man
selbstbewusst ist und klar ich Fan von
knack Geschichte und ja mir istich
wichtig dass man da gerade im Kontext V
dem W steck der wachstumstrategie aber
der Kapital finde D mus und wel
Botschaft sind wichtig füren übergeordn
Plan
SP
C
1943 fand die erste Olma statt die
versorgungsenkpässe aus dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg erhöhten die Interessen für
die Landwirtschaft den Anbau und die
Milchwirtschaft Produkte zur
schaustellen aufklären und waren
verkaufen waren damals wie noch heute
tragende Elemente auch die Tiere gehören
seit Beginn der Messe
dazu getragen wird die Olma von einer
Genossenschaft das starke Fundament
bilden die Stadt St Gallen und Kantone
aus der Ostschweiz seit Jahren finden
auf dem molma Areal in den Messehallen
auch eine Frühlingsmesse
bildungsausstellungen und zahlreiche
Veranstaltungen statt gegen 130 pro Jahr
90 Angestellte arbeiten dafür dass die
Hallen stets ausgelastet sind
Jahresumsatz 30 Millionen und dann kam
Corona weil die Genossenschaft zu einem
großen Teil von der öffentlichen Hand
getragen wird bekam sie keine
härtefallgelder vom Bund dieser
Delegierte an stattung Kanton me WR
Pandemie fast Z Jahr nicht könen
schaffen wenn aber schfangen bauen das
heißt das ganze ersparte ist im Bau
festbund gie wir sind ziemlich schnelle
liquiditäts sie schaffen im Moment auch
wi der Funktion als Retterin von der
Olma Messe also überhaupt eigentlich nur
was ist mit dem Job als
Direktorin der MA ich auch noch aber das
F h war ein Spaß beiseite ja Gastgeberin
sie da undspruch halte natürlich
unternehm vertrte Führer von der
geschäftsleit die aufgab hät sowieso und
da macht auch jetzt ein großen Teil A
ihr arbeitspensium liege aktuell bei
160% manchmal auch noch
höher Z wohl wohl
D deshalb gibt es kaum freizit heute
aber trifft Christine Bolt ihre besten
Freundinnen aus dem tockenburg welche
sie schon seit über 30 Jahren kennt ihr
Ziel ist die süffige degustationshalle
den wsen wenn da ist es ih Arbeitsplatz
den ist es die Welt sie kennt und mit
schw und dann ist so und ist okay ist
anders wenn sie da unterwegs
ist ja natürlich sie ist da sie
repräsentiert
RLE natürlich sie privaticht
no ja
[Musik]
ja aber ist nicht so dass total zwei
verschiedene
Gesichter außerhalb ihr arbeitszeitä sie
keine Möglichkeit Geldgeber und mögliche
Aktionäre
anzusprechen
wie
Super G alles
GÜ
C
natürlich diese degustationshalle hat
ihren eigenen Zauber und macht viele
Leute redselig meine Behauptung ist ja
dass die degustationshalle das
eigentlich größte Magnet für die
Besucherinnen und Besucher ist und darum
auch viel zum Bestehen der Messe
beiträgt wenn nicht am meisten mit
Zahlen lässt sich dies natürlich nicht
belegen
ja also
Spezi viel wert aber Kritik jeder
wei
B
aber
media
s immered Diskussion mit so und so
schnell
denken
aber seh
langs das im der olessen hat gelitten
nicht wegen Corona sonder weil die
öffentliche Hand die mit finanzpriten
retten
muss Laune kommt der
Kater zwei Monate später geht es im
Kantonsrat wiederum Geld und wiederum
die Olma der grüne Politiker Thomas
Schwager möchte einen Riegel
schieben es wird zum Fass ohne BDE und
drum ist jetzt richtig zpunkt zum dafür
Sorge dass der Kanton s GAL nicht noch
Geld in das Loch in wirft schon wenige
Monate zuvor ging es um Steuergeld ein
8,6 Millionen Franken Darlehen soll in
Eigenkapital der Olma gewandelt werden
heute geht es um den gaskanton an der
Olma das Tessin hat für
2024 abgesagt aus Spargründen nun
schlägt die Saller Regierung vor mit dem
eigenen Kanton in die Bresche zu
springen kostenpunkt 1,2 Millionen
Franken einige sehen darin eine
versteckte Subvention oder Sinnlosigkeit
andere Chance hätten wir die Richtlinien
immer
schwarzweiß schwarzweiß ausgelegt es
hätten verschiedene Gesuche nicht
bewilligt werden können dieser
lotteriefon bietet auch mit den
Richtlinien die wir haben Spielraum wir
sind wenige m noch der Diskussion im
Februar wieder am gichenort s noch
Million gesprochen werden und irgendwenn
ist einfach der Zapfen ab irgendw muss
sich selber könen finanzieren und selber
verantworttig träge dass das Geld in für
die
Investion wieder sagte das Parlament ja
und stimmte zu dass der heimkanton St
Gallen an der Olma Werbung für sich
selber macht zudem kann die Olma 17
Millionen Darlehen von Stadt und Kanton
in Eigenkapital wandeln ein erstes
Etappenziel ist geschafft Kantonsrat
bleibt kritisch tale ist zweiummer groß
für stad ST g sie ist sehr dür und zum
das rentab Betriebe W super gutas und D
ich einfach die der
Businessplan vit der vorberaten der
Kommission das wirklich tragfähig ist
mus
wirklichbringt ich glaub bis zu
24 pro Jahr 20
25 Kön es machen mit Comedy mit
Konzert ST Gale wirklich der
Ort strömet und die Hal fühl also ich
glaub es hat mich ger dass gewisse l die
die Bühne einfach für ihre politisch
Karriere genutzt letztlich wir nicht
dafür für finanziellf m Team verwaltsrat
und D setze Tag und Nacht alles D
irgendwie diemesse fürz überleb und da
Moment Unterstützig gewünscht hab wir
machen nicht fürü sondern für stschwitz
das neue Prestigeobjekt die Halle 1 sie
ist doppelt so groß wie die größte
bestehende Halle mit einer Fläche so
groß wie eineinhalb Fußballfelder
kostenpkt 180 Millionen w e gern da vol
Gumpe aber noch Referate Buch die
H Halle ist riesig größer als alle
andere Halle wo sie s die stte größer
waren v
mtigen Entscheid ist für ostschwizer
sicher sehr groß aber ich glaub wenn man
W bis Großreich und groß Welt STR nicht
schlecht mal groß aber der zpunkt ist
der falsch zum groß denke das nicht fr
GLB V Jahr entschieden dass man da macht
vor 6 Jahr volkit und ich
covidur es gibt veränd Markt aber merken
jetzt ja D es sehr gut funktioniert mit
der Messe mit Events mit groß nachag
[Gelächter]
hallo nicht so dass S alle persönlich ke
mit
Name wegen diesem Dach prasselt weitere
Kritik auf Christine boltein der Auftrag
geht in einen anderen Kontinent eine
chinesische Firma konstruiert das Dach
über 20 Chinesen arbeiten während
Monaten in St Gallen gibt kein Schwizer
wo das System aber viel Schwizer sie w
mit dem
systemarbeit
kooperier leider alle
Abig der Welt wo es GT niert Z Europäer
und chines Europäer sind eine 3 million
6 Millionen und zicher dass sie
überhaupt ke ST lieferen wegen der Krise
Ukraine wrussland und der chines fix
günstiger und ganz fix li
unded dass die Zuverlässigkeit wichtiger
ist damit der Bau fertig stellen und
recht angen könnt die H
bewirtschaftte das Besondere am Dach es
ist über die ganze Fläche stützenfrei
und an vielen hängepunkten stark
belastbar die offizielle halleneröffnung
ist im Frühling sofern es keine
Überraschungen mehr gibt stellen hier
bereits an der Olma die ersten
Aussteller
aus vorstell denn wenn Olma ist und H
inne Erlebnis narig der regioomarkt all
die Essens trinkenständ und alles für
ein Platz
mega
cool der wichtigste Tag des Jahres steht
an genossenschaftlerinnen und
Genossenschaftler entscheiden über das
rechtskleid der Olm messen entstehen s
eine Aktiengesellschaft mit der
Möglichkeit mehr Fremdkapital
aufzunehmen dies ist der Grundstein für
den angedachten Rettungsplan aus der
Misere hoffe es gut aber grundsätzlich
ist mehr vorfre wie Respekt mit Sch ich
glaube ich habe ja tatsächlich Glück
dass ich viel Energie hab grundsätzlich
vi zu vericht hab mir bringt so schnell
nicht a der
Ruhe ist
heiß ne gibt den felis also es ist schon
ein großer
[Musik]
Tag
Corona Loch V
[Musik]
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
million
jetzt ja ist jetzt Druck weg oder ST
druckag so B ein Berg geil ein Berg
gchaff ich sch ist groß V allem D das da
unglaublich vertrau
und fah Referat alles hat sich gelohnt
das ist ein großer großer weg aber da
schöne wertschätzig und git viel
vertrauenl über
bergin genau über Berg aber zweite und
ein dritte aber mit ger
bergstiege
geil
superoh
wow danke viel
wenn jetzt 10 Millionen Aktienkapital
binand W geschafft D knossenschaft ohne
gwandelt worden ist und wir sind
operativ vor anderhalb Jahr wieder sehr
gut gestartet wir sind jetzt sehr gut
unterwegs und wir sagen wir sind gut
Zwischenpunkt Bolt ist eine die den
Hobel ansetzt und wo gehobelt wird
fallen Späne in diesem Fall sind es
Menschen die intern umplatziert oder
degradiert werden Mitte Mai verkündet
sie
imaktion wir Meng wir sehr schnell
schäer BU für Meng
wir und und ich
GLB veruckt
werde was ma mit den verruckt werd ma es
ist Geschicht da wenn Sie da wenn Sie
Frage erkl aber ist nicht von
geschäftsle Z Mens glücklich ma sondern
zum Unternehmen führen mit de Menschen
dass S sich wohlfühl beim Schaffen und
da kommt halt vor dass man
sich dass man mal muss Entscheid treffen
wo nicht zu populär
sind Bolt will nicht dass wir sie hier
Filmen zu heikel sie sagte mir aber
später dass F bis 10 Personen der
insgesamt 90 Mitarbeiter gekündigt haben
oder sich nach neuen Jobs
umschauen die OL Direktorin ist beliebt
als Referentin bekannt in der ganzen
Ostschweiz deshalb wurde Christine Bolt
angefragt für eine er augustr inenzell
auf dem Kronberg Treffpunkt morgens um 5
mit dabei Gotte Schwester Mutter und der
Ehemann
wie nein es ist nicht da es ist Verus
nein
[Musik]
B auch auf dem Berg sind die Zeiten
stürmisch guten Morgen mit Z am 1
August genau 4 Minuten
früh 7 Minuten früh als bel minut fr
Bern und gchlagen 1 Minuten frh alsf li
g mehr sind
der jeeden Tag
und nach dem offiziellen Teil reist
derjäh ehanneter vus ins Ferienhaus in
alterim
Haus die Damen nehmen den Weg zu
Fuß so
schön weiß nicht wann ihr
[Musik]
HT
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
danke he doch
da mit dem sindig
Thema Kind
aber und schaff me wichtig ja wir
[Musik]
konzentri
aufgewachsen in Wildhaus und eins
tourismusdirektorin im tockenburg zieht
es Christine Bolt oft zurück zu ihren
Wurzeln sie hält hier mit den Schwestern
eine Zweitwohnung für Sommerferien und
zum
Skifahren das ist
fachsen sind dieses helterus n aber es
ist vom FL her sehr lich und das ist
elich wie möglich zum sich d tre Familie
Hauptpunkt und das mir mega wichtig und
fin schön
ich jetzt nicht da le im Moment es wär
und
ich
urban im Geist und haltigellig aber für
und weiß wie sich levölkfühlt und
diete so eine moderne
Lavalampe
lustig Schatz mit eh peter ist sie seit
12 Jahren zusammen seit 4 Jahren
verheiratet mir Schü auffall dass sie
oft und schnell der den Aug vorstellt
wenn sie ne sind warum ist das so dass
es kein missverständnisön geh oder h
schon mal
geh g mir ist wichtig dass wisen dass
Peter ist also B sehr glücklich dass er
viel ist und das
natürlich rech and Unterschied und ab
und zu auch das Glück me Vater da nürich
logisch er ist nur Z jah jünger wie me
Vater und Z J ter wie meine Mutter aber
ich glaub wir auch machen wenn man Gicht
wer am Anfang komisch g und mega gewnt
un und es ist jetzt B
so da diskutiert und mit allenfah und
Nachteil und war
das ja ja das wo sind wo sind der vor
oder
Nachteil Vorteil ist g D dass
ich in die Pol B also ich hab hinter mir
also in D sin dass ich irgendwo Stress
oder
irgendwie
fremdbestimmig und das ist glaub der
Vorteil also dann kanr mal Sachen Ablad
wo wo sie vielleicht nie anders
ablade ist ein wichtigge Teil V ganz
dass ich da
vielesushalte der R Pol der Brauch sie
ja ich bra R Pol und die Sicherheit und
und und so die Nestwärme und einfach der
der halt da für mich extrem wichtig
danke viel
mal
viel was ne du hast das
gemacht Mitte August bekommt die neue
olmerhle 1 einen Namen dank diesem
Sponsoringvertrag spült es gutes Geld in
die olmkasse wie viel bleibt geheim ich
starte groß befreigeschlag es ist ein
Witter großer Schritt aufem lange weg
befreigeschlag W jetzt groß griffen aber
ist ganzis wichtig fürü finanziell aber
Zeiche für Genus wir es geschafft
Partner wo pas und und das
G ein starker strategischer Schachzug
denn jetzt ist die Kreditgeberin Stall
Kantonalbank noch stärker an die OL
gebunden für Sie beruhigfüh wenn
Sie Kantonalbank laufen sie WS sie auch
Staatsgarantie lange Partnerschaft mit W
und sich ja es gibt ein sehr gut Gefühl
die Verkündigung hat
Strahlkraft trotz der Geldprobleme für
die anderen Hallen komme ein
namensponsoring nicht in Frage
versicherte mir Bolt sie sind die der
FDP
gkantong V FDP regiersr be der
Kantonalbank Sitz FDP Kolleg
verwaltsrat t Bau auf FDP die Ken NAT
der
verwal FDP ehemalige Stadtpräsident ist
politung nein W nicht viel Ken alle ich
k aber viel Politikerin und Politiker V
anderen
Parteiungen vi das Mens sich für stand
für und für die regionale Wirtschaft und
für dieich Partei ich politisch aktiv
ich Partei aber keamt und engag
jetzt will genau will denke ich muss
unabhängig unabhängig Christine Bolt
hätte im Spätsommer die Möglichkeit
gehabt selber für die FDP in den
Kantonsrat nachzurücken sie lehnte ab
ihre Mission habe
Priorität es ist Ende September nur noch
wenige Tage bis zur Olma die ersten
Messestände in der neuen Halle werden
aufgestellt stand ja Weber knussmcht ja
genau das knusm Weber mit dem Turm
und
Element
oder es ist
Berg sehr
viel Betrieb D das da möglich ist sehr
vi super gchaff da noch spannend bis zum
Schluss schaffen ja daslich wier h
GFF B bis dieigent
Betrieb geswitzt immer D der klappet
ungebremste Zuversicht und viel
Optimismus so habe ich Christine Bolt
die letzten Monate erlebt geht nicht
gibt's nicht auch wenn es oft ein
Balanceakt
war so das sind neue büer seeh schön aus
hell frünlich W lange weg se V sie h
viel energiebuch zum Millionen Z Samml
was hab sie erreicht ja so aufs Ganze
geseh hab schon ziemlich viel geldbracht
al 27 Millionen hmer Teil kommt jetzt
Geschäftstätigkeit jetzt brauchchen wir
noch ze also ich sage jetzt mal wir sind
gut unterwegs haben fast Viertel binand
aber die letzte 25% W natürlich no
anstrengend anspruchsvoll aber ja man h
doch einiges erreicht im letzte Jahr zur
Rettungsmission droht weiteres Ungemach
eine Messehalle die Halle ne muss wegen
dem Ausbau des Autobahntunnels unterbaut
oder gar abgebrochen werden die stellt
die Olma innen und außen nochmals
komplett auf den Kopf wenn das mit der
drit Röhre teiluch von Halle eventuell
die ganz abbrechen neubauen das
wäre normale Direktorin da sind sie
bauchfin g normal noch
gar krisenmodus sind
transformationsmodus sind im
wachstumsmodus GLB ist wie richtige le
im Wied
und die
ist die Rettung der Olma wie eine
Bergtour in ihrer tockenburger Heimat
mal geht es hoch und dann auch wieder
ein paar Schritte runter aber mein
Eindruck ist sie ist mit sicherem
Schritt und gutem Mutes
unterwegs